temperatures a Visionary and that's how  I see him as like he was the first one  to think of the Bold like content and  getting famous that fast like I don't  know if you know how he got his content  everywhere no people in Hustler's  University it was one of the affiliate  programs where basically he would tell  them a way to make money is to post his  content and use his Hustlers program as  the link in the bio okay so if they  posted his Clips the the kids or whoever  could make money by putting his Link in  the bio I could make a couple hundred  bucks right so and he would teach them  how to make clips and stuff and I'm like  that's genius